buonasera
bella questa immagine no casa nostra
bisogna tenerla un po bene no compito
nostro anche io sono un architetto
grazie alla mia architettura che è la
mia passione tra l'altro ho avuto la
possibilità di conoscere il mondo di
viaggiare e di vedere diverse culture
diversi luoghi diversi climi diverse
attività in cui svolgere il mio mestiere
vengo qua a presentarvi quattro proposte
quattro idee e quattro progetti che
stiamo costruendo che stiamo realizzando
e che abbiamo realizzato in giro per il
mondo
ovviamente l'idea è quella di avere come
protagonista l'acqua perché in tutti
questi progetti l'acqua stato un tipico
esempio per noi la russia come sapete è
un clima a un clima molto difficile un
inverno forte con estate forte anche mi
ricordo nel 2010 le temperature e noi
vorremmo come leggete qua arrivare ad
avere una simbiosi una simbiosi
nell'architettura in cui l'inverno e
complementare all'estate in cui tutte le
attività che compongono un edificio
possono integrarsi dentro un ambiente
abbiamo iniziato a lavorare su questo
progetto
circa due anni fa che stiamo portando
avanti un progetto che un mix diverso
quindi un progetto che lavora 24 ore su
24 e in un paese come la russia che
vende l'energia avere un progetto che
vuole avere un risparmio energetico è un
esempio importante da portare dentro il
nostro edificio o dentro i nostri
edifici abbiamo residenziale commerciale
terziario e quindi come diceva un
edificio che lavora 24 ore
ovviamente l'edificio non si deve
integrare solo nella città si deve
integrare anche nell'ambiente questo
edificio dove parlare russo a ruschi
kavaric quindi è importante che noi
iniziamo integrarlo
iniziamo a lavorare con il sole e con la
pioggia con la terra
iniziamo a lavorare con l'aria perché
comunque sono elementi che compongono
anche l'ambiente in cui viene inserito
il sole ovviamente tenendo in
considerazione l'estate e l'inverno che
ci ovviamente ci dà un orientamento
ovviamente anche ci dà la possibilità di
avere cellule fotovoltaiche di avere
pone pannelli solari che vanno a servire
ovviamente come supporto al sistema di
riscaldamento
abbiamo la possibilità di avere delle
doppie pelle grazie alle tecnologie che
abbiamo adesso in modo di avere delle
circolazioni d'aria naturale e abbiamo
anche la possibilità di raccogliere le
acque piovane
ma non solo le acque piovane che servono
per la parte diciamo di irrigazione dei
giardini oppure diciamo quello che può
essere ivc diciamo i sanitari ma anche
il ghiaccio diciamo in questo caso noi
stiamo facendo in modo che la neve che
noi raccogliamo durante l'inverno possa
essere utilizzata durante l'estate in
modo che questo incrementi e possa far
sì che un impianto di condizionamento
lavori a un livello molto più basso
quindi diciamo la simbiosi di un
progetto non nasce solo da una funzione
o da una forma nasce anche da una
funzionalità e da un rispetto che questa
deve avere qua vedete in questo schema
come viene al mazzella come viene
stoccata diciamo il ghiaccio per tenerlo
diciamo freddo durante l'estate abbiamo
la geotermia che ormai un sistema
diffuso
ripeto il fotovoltaico il solare termico
le acque piovane e tutto questo tutto
questo crea la nostra simbiosi quindi
sino ad oggi abbiamo parlato di
architettura ma fino a un certo punto
l'architettura non è solo una forma
l'architettura non è solo bellezza ma
l'architettura deve essere qualcosa che
deve essere un elemento completo è vivo
e in questo progetto e stiamo cercando
di farlo
da lì andiamo altro tipo di clima altro
tipo di paesaggio
ovviamente siamo in questo caso in libia
dove lavoriamo in un edificio esistente
in questo caso l'edificio parla italiano
perché un edificio fatto negli anni
quaranta da un architetto italiano equa
lavoriamo su una struttura esistente
dove la caratteristica di questo
edificio è una corte interna perché
ovviamente come un tempo si facevano gli
edifici a corte su questa corte
l'edificio ha dato completamente le
spalle senso la corte viene trattata
come se fosse un elemento di retro senso
in cui la pioggia entra in cui il sole
non riesce nemmeno a penetrare e la
corte viene vista in un modo molto
negativo allora noi dobbiamo fare in
modo che quella parte negativa diventi
positiva in cui la corte si apra sì al
centro dell'edificio in modo di creare
uno assi avere uno spazio dentro il
quale in un paese dove il verde ce n'è
poco e quando uno lo trova e molto
contento inserirlo veramente li facendo
in modo che questa corte apra
completamente l'edificio
ma vediamo un esempio costruito diciamo
prima e dopo
e la corte ovviamente è un elemento dove
la vegetazione fa l'isolamento acustico
fa ovviamente di rigenerazione pulizia
dell'area fa in modo che il sole penetri
direttamente agli uffici e fa in modo
che diciamo ci sia un rapporto visivo da
uno spazio all'altro aprendola
completamente e dobbiamo ovviamente
evitare che l'acqua vada dentro abbiamo
inserito una copertura di vetro
ovviamente il vetro ha un potere
diradamento molto forte le temperature
sono molto forti li e quindi attraverso
un sistema fotovoltaico per la raccolta
dell'energia
abbiamo attivato delle pompe d'acqua che
fa sì che l'acqua sia in continuo
movimento sulla copertura di vetro
quindi quando il sole
arriva sulla copertura non c'è
l'irraggiamento attraverso del vetro si
no colpisce l'acqua la quale in continuo
movimento e la quale a sua volta abbassa
la temperatura interna dello spazio in
cui viene inserito il nostro assi lì
dentro abbiamo posizionato tutte le
circolazione tutti gli ascensori e scale
in modo che sia il centro quello che un
giorno era una parte negativa del
progetto possa essere un elemento
completamente positivo in modo di
rivitalizzarlo e ovvio che qua stiamo
parlando di un edificio esistente
quindi gli interventi sono molto mirati
queste quasi un lavoro da chirurgo
mentre il progetto di mosca che abbiamo
visto precedentemente è un lavoro exnovo
dove abbiamo una capacità di innovare
nel momento in cui lo costruiamo qua la
situazione cambia una cosa durante i
miei viaggi che mi ha colpito è che ci
sono dei paesi che hanno delle ricchezze
idriche impressionanti
parliamo della giorgia parliamo della
colombia dove ci sono risorse molto
molto molto importanti dal punto di
vista idrico
purtroppo però manca la tecnologia
se io quando sono stato in arabia
saudita e ho visto i campi agricoli in
cui crescevano dal nulla
in un paese dove c'è la sabbia ma c'è
una tecnologia a volte questi contrasti
portano a farsi delle domande del perché
in certe situazioni a volte quando
abbiamo troppo non li diamo il valore a
quello che abbiamo adesso rimaniamo in
colombia
andiamo a una realtà completamente
diversa
siamo nei caraibi siamo a barbanti già
non ci sono le stagioni non abbiamo le
condizioni che ci sono in russia
e qua parliamo di un edificio che
purtroppo dico purtroppo lavora poco e
ore durante l'anno e stiamo parlando di
un ex di un centro espositivo di un
centro congressi e quindi questi spazi
hanno una vita molto limitata
molto spesso sono dei mei all'interno
della città perché nel momento in cui
vivono
a volte provocano disagio a volte no
allora e quindi abbiamo cercato di
animare questo edificio
abbiamo un edificio piuttosto grande
abbiamo diviso in due zone
ovviamente lo spazio abbiamo inserito da
una parte la parte espositiva e
dall'altra la zona congressi senza però
in nessun momento togliere una
continuità tra la città e il fiume
c'è da dire che a parlanti già arriva
uno dei fiumi più importanti della
colombia che il fiume maddalena e quindi
è un posto dove in qualche modo c'è la
presenza dell'acqua molto forte oltre
ovviamente all acqua diciamo di mare che
si trova lì anche qua abbiamo applicato
lo stesso principio che abbiamo fatto
nel progetto della libia dove attraverso
un sistema passivo di energia come sono
diciamo fotovoltaico abbiamo di nuovo
attivato una pompa ma in questo caso
l'abbiamo messo all'esterno
dell'edificio
in particolare sulla zona che riguarda
ovviamente la sala congressi
questo ovviamente per ovviare e per
animare questa situazione quade
dell'edificio rimane vuoto
molto spesso è quindi molto spesso
questo è un neo all'interno della città
il fatto di creare due strutture
separate significa che ognuna ha un
autonomia
diciamo da un punto di vista energetico
completamente diversa molto spesso c'è
un di sperdimento di energia in quanto
abbiamo delle grosse strutture però li
usiamo solo parzialmente in questo caso
invece abbiamo cercato di dividerli
perché così nel momento in cui una
lavora non è subordinata completamente
all'altra quindi diciamo tutti gli
oggetti architettonici che sono stati
studiati e visti in questo progetto non
solo hanno una risposta architettonica
sino a sua volta hanno anche una
risposta tecnica e soprattutto cercano
di migliorare e in qualche modo di
risparmiare
un po quello che sono le risorse più
importanti qua vediamo come l'acqua
stessa all'interno dell'edificio nel
senso questa facciata senza l'acqua
sarebbe una struttura completamente
statica in questo caso diventa una
struttura molto attiva e per ultimo io
vorrei parlare di un progetto con cui
che ho fatto insieme un grande
architetto e progetto che abbiamo
ultimato un progetto nell'acqua teso
dentro l'acqua e che contiene acqua in
questo caso parliamo dell'ampliamento
della curia di genova è un edificio che
avevamo costruito in un cantiere navale
abbiamo trasportato via mare nel sito
dove in questo momento esiste e che
porta all'interno una vita una vita che
non è simile alla nostra
però la quale ci ha portato a farci
molti quesiti molte domande quindi è la
prima volta in cui ci siamo trovati a
fare un progetto che non è fatto per le
persone ma abbiamo creato una vita
completamente diverso e quindi diciamo
l'obiettivo di questa mia presentazione
facendo riferimento a queste quattro
tipologie di costruzioni in queste
quattro tipologie di luoghi sul fatto
che noi architetti non possiamo
semplicemente limitare la nostra
architettura a creare l'apertura o la
chiusura di un rubinetto o dare un
servizio limitato sino cercare di
prendere di ogni luogo dove andiamo
il meglio che abbiamo a disposizione
grazie